I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
I was not act necessarily the most
active kid I was active with the fork
eaten pretty yeah I was pretty active
with the fork so I had a nickname which
I didn't know what it meant but it was
Bob and I am not thinking is my
brother's gave it to me I'm gonna
youngest say buddies call me Bob I'm
feeling good like oh I got a nickname so
I'm one cool guys
and we would Ronnie may jump there
jumping over fence and I'm having
trouble getting over the fence and
wonder friends helped me over he go you
know what we call you Bob yeah I mean
booty on back
what yeah like you got a big old butt
yeah I'm back Bob big old butt Bob I'm
my funny story now but how did that make
you feel then I like horrible like I
cried I remember 13 year old boy
thinking I'm cool I was that they break
me down so I cried over that but it was
i literally decided at that point I okay
I can't I don't want to be Bob anymore
so I bought the Jane Fonda workout video
VHS tapes us where are you
VJ Jane Fonda come on Jane Fonda's
legendary so I bought I didn't have this
pan deccan stuff but I had to VHS tape I
had to tape start doing the leg lifts
and like back and butt side lifts for my
butt and then I bought the Herschel
Walker workout book because Herschel
Walker was coming on University of
Georgia he was like the man and I
started doing push-ups and sit-ups and I
would watch TV so if they'd watch
dynasty or something and commercial
breaks I would do push-ups sit-ups and
do my Jane Fonda leg lifts and do
crunches then there's programmer come on
out watch and then every commercial
break and after months of this my dad
said you know what we'll work out
together because he was a boxer all army
boxer and everything else so we went to
the gym we started going to the gym and
I was 13 and when I was 16 he said you
know what let's send you to Houston
you're gonna stay with your uncle you're
gonna get a football scholarship and I'm
and I was naive I'm so I was like glad
to color my shirt so green
like okay alright no idea what the heck
I would do it
I watched football on TV at that point I
hadn't played in years before you know
high school so I went back to Houston
stay with my uncle art who had played
seven years in the NFL and he would take
me in the front yard and slap me around
and showed me different stuff I had no
idea what he was talking about went to
high school didn't know a quarterback
sack was like important I didn't know I
can just have us no idea I was just
running around whoever got the ball I
guess that's who I'd go get and I had
one scholarship to Texas Southern do you
realize how crazy that story is I'm
telling you I'm a lucky man I don't look
lucky man yeah but luck doesn't get you
to do leg lifts and get the videos and
do push-ups and sit-ups during
commercial breaks when you're watching
TV does that wait you know it was a
great lesson I look back now though you
know what it was it was something I
think about now
and you could change anything you want
there's something you don't like change
it it's something you don't like change
it and for me that was the first moment
in my life I realized I didn't like
being called Bob I didn't like being
heavy like that so I changed it so if
there's any circumstances in my life now
that I don't like I make the decision a
conscious decision to change it and and
some are Hayek said something to me one
time which I always think about as well
so you cannot complain about something
you're not trying to change yeah I was
like whoa so I I think back it was kind
of like that mentality I couldn't go oh
man I'm there called me Bob and then
complain about it not changing it
you